hello everybody my name is jake and
welcome back to another elden ring build
guide video for me these videos are a
lot of fun to make because i love
messing around with kind of the offbeat
weapons of this game maybe weapons that
people didn't even know you could get
you know just kind of going with a
certain like theme on a build and
absolutely running with it the build i'm
about to show you this absolutely insane
bleed build is so much fun i'm not
trying to give you the most overpowered
build in the game you can find a ton of
those anywhere you want i've been
playing this game a lot and i can't stop
playing it i'm still having fun playing
this game even a month close to a month
after release i'm going to show you guys
some clips really quick of me killing
some bosses and some enemies in the game
with this current build
what
all right trying to hit me with your
plate
god damn
4k
damage oh my god random bleed
wow
give me the bleed there it is
3400 on that bleed
oh that bleed damage did
43 right there
4300 damage on that
oh 8700
my god
so as you can see this this build does a
lot of bleed damage a lot of blood loss
and it stacks very quickly you can get
some blood loss going pretty quick so
let's go over
all of our main stats off the rip let's
go over that first so obviously i'm an
insanely high level 220. if you're going
for a bleed build from like start finish
you don't have to be level 220 to do
this build not at all you can be between
level 100 120 to 80 like
i will show you guys the main stats that
you need to use these weapons and then
you can base it off of that so on this
account i'm sitting at 60 vigor you
don't need 60 vigor the first soft cap
for vigor is actually 40. so i would
definitely implore you to get up to 40
maybe even focus on hitting 60 vigor
because this game a lot of enemies
one shot you they kill you in one or two
hits and you're dead vigor is probably
one of the most important
attributes on any build that you make in
eldon ring so i would definitely focus
on vigor when it comes to mine i just
wanted enough fp to be able to do
moog's
blood ritual
which does a ton of damage once you get
the bleed build up you can hold it down
like it is just so much fun to use this
thing on big groups of people and then
it has this cool after effect like the i
love how bleed and blood in this game is
like mixed with fire i think that's like
a really cool mix of two things is fire
and bleed and of course with our rivers
of blood katana we can do the bloody
slash
does a ton of damage as well you also
get really decent range with the rivers
of blood like this reaches pretty pretty
far it's not like you're a source or
anything shooting across the arena but
you get some you get some distance with
it so two weapons that can be used up
close
and from far away in their own ashes of
war for endurance i just went with 50
the soft caps for endurance are 25 50
and then if you have a medallion that
increases your endurance that can also
like the hard cap with a medallion is 60
endurance i just stuck with 50. you
don't really need to go higher than that
i've never needed more than 50 endurance
so when it comes to strength you don't
really need it the only requirement for
strength that we need is 25 to be able
to use the mogwon's palace spear
otherwise we just wouldn't level
strength at all so just try and get your
strength to 25. the soft caps per
strength are 20 55 and then 80. to
really flush out this build and kind of
min max your attributes you don't really
need to put any points into strength
anything over than 25 is completely
unnecessary strength doesn't make you
stronger with this build arcane does
which i'm about to get to next is
dexterity 55 we wanted dexterity to be
able to just get off these moves as fast
as we possibly can we're sitting at 55
because that is the second soft cap for
dexterity dexterity soft caps are 20 55
and then 80. i think 80 is unnecessary
you don't really need to go that high
unless you're really wanting to go with
the dual bloody katanas which you
absolutely can do you can put less
points maybe into arcane and vigor and
more points into dexterity if you really
wanted to flush that whole thing out
intelligence and faith are not needed
with this build so don't worry about
leveling them at all then we get to the
big one arcane even on this character
i'm trying to get my arcane up to 80
because the soft caps for arcane are 20
50 and 80. every time i level arcane it
goes up three four points at a time so
the the damage that i do with all the
weapons rivers of blood at plus 10 uh
dual wielding them and moguin's sacred
spirit plus 10 i'm just doing more and
more damage so for this build in
particular i would recommend to you to
focus on arcane that's where you're
gonna get the big blood loss damage the
faster bleeds you know where you have
you don't have to do as many hits to get
that bleed effect off on your opponents
so i'm still leveling this character all
you have to do is focus on your vigor
your dexterity and your arcane and just
getting strength to 25 and you're pretty
much good you don't really need much
more than that when it comes to mind try
and get that as high as you possibly can
just to have a good amount of fp so that
you can do the cool moves that this this
character has when it comes to the
talismans this is really all preference
in my opinion i'm sure there's some
really good
bleed blood loss things but these are
the ones that i personally like to use i
like not getting one shot which happens
a lot in this game especially in new
game plus three that i'm at now
i like not getting hit once and dying so
i use the dragon crest shield talisman
which vastly boosts my physical damage
negation it's not huge none of these
talismans really do all that much to be
honest but they're fun to have warrior
jar shard is next that boosts the attack
power of my skills so what that does is
just boost the damage that i do when i
use skills like this
so this is never going to be a bad
talisman to have faker's cameo restores
hp upon defeating enemies i kill an
enemy i get a little bit hp back sounds
good to me godskin swaddling cloth
successive attacks restore hp and that
goes really well when i'm dual wielding
my katanas getting that blood build up
just annihilating opponents like this
you can get some really quick blood loss
uh just by doing the main attacks and
especially when you're doing the bloody
slashes
you get some distance have a lot of
options with this build again i focus on
having the most fun not it being like
perfectly mid maxing which i think if
you're really focused on that you can do
that yourself leave a comment down below
to just make this build better i'm
always looking for feedback so don't be
shy to put it in the comments when it
comes to the fit the clothes the armor
that i'm wearing it's all preference
armor doesn't really do that much in
elden ring so i just wanted to look cool
so the first thing i got going on here
is the great helm i love swagger souls i
think it's funny it reminds me of dark
souls 1 reminds me of swagger souls and
it matches the rest of the fit as well
we have the sanguine mobile robe as you
know this is like kind of what the
followers of moog the lord of blood the
prince of blood he wears
clothes like this so for a bleed build i
thought it really fit the theme and then
the greaves and the gauntlets are just
hoslow's gear i just thought it matched
the helm and that it matched the kind of
red aesthetic of the rest of the build
you know blood being red the fire blood
loss in this game being red as well the
kind of red accents with the shiny like
silver armor with the gauntlets and the
helmet and the red uh kind of accents
with the robe that i'm wearing i think
it looks really cool this character guys
this build is just so much fun i'm
planning on doing a walkthrough of this
build so starting from the beginning and
working our way all the way through the
game to get a build similar to this one
kind of showing you where i went how i
got it let me know if that's something
that interests you i've had a lot of
requests for it so i've just been
thinking of the best way that i could do
that appreciate all the support on the
videos lately we're getting a lot of
subs a lot of views i just really
appreciate it guys another thing i'll
tell you is that you should go to my
twitch channel i stream all the time
we're playing elden ring all the time
we're coming up with builds we're we're
lore hunting we're doing everything in
this game i'm trying to learn everything
i can about this game so go check out
the twitch channel thank you so much for
watching the video leave some ideas down
below some feedback some whatever you
want like the video subscribe don't
forget to subscribe a lot of people do
forget to do that and i'll see you guys
in the next one